le téléfilm moins grosse diffusé hier
soir sur france 2 accusés de racisme de
grossophobie de publicité clandestine ou
d'abord et pour le congé mec benjamin
castaldi encore à la finition initiale
ballon comme on dit à l'adresse des
grâces et oui soit accusé de grosses
sommes
alors hier donc france 2 proposait une
soirée consacrée à la grossophobie un
téléfilm intitulé moi gross était
diffusée suivie d'un débat et le
téléfilm a cependant été l'objet d'une
polémique car il est accusé de
grossophobie voulez savoir pourquoi vous
explique tout ça en vidéo s'est préparée
par gégé guillaume genton que j'embrasse
c'est parti
c'est partout la grossophobie le fait de
discriminer des individus en raison de
leur surpoids est de plus en plus
présent dans le débat public
hier soir france 2 diffuse et moi grosse
un téléfilm sur le sujet voter c'est
délicat mais voilà nous sommes dans un
centre de loisirs et des parents disent
que vous faites car aux enfants une
fiction suivi par 3 millions 100 mille
téléspectateurs et 14 % du public qui
n'a pourtant pas fait l'unanimité
de nombreux téléspectateurs ont accusé
la production de grossophobie en effet
pendant le tournage juliette katz
l'héroïne à porter un accessoire sous
ses vêtements pour paraître plus
corpulente un choix qui a choqué de
nombreuses militante anti grossophobie
je tombe des nues avec le fast food de
moi grosse insidieuse et sournoise cette
violence enrobé de bienveillance et
réelle
j'avais beau ne rien attendre c'est une
méchante gifle le fath soute une
combinaison rembourré pour paraître plus
corpulent et pourtant une pratique assez
fréquentes au cinéma notamment à
l'international
alors moi perso j'ai pas ce que vous en
pensez le bandeau les déprimes colérique
est ce que vous trouvez que c'est une
polémique qui a eu mal au ventre a dit
habib normand moi je trouvais que
c'était au contraire très important
montrer ça parce que les personnes de
très très forte corpulence voire obèses
sont stigmatisés et je crois qu'il y
avait rien de choquant ni dans le
téléfilm ni dans le débat après il ya
aucun problème même en france 2 et sur
les défendre ils ont voulu faire ça
justement pour dénoncer et bien sûr un
nom génial et après on mettra une le
truc comme les réseaux sociaux à des
fins il voit souvent des polémiques
partout quoi donc l'effet spécial à la
wii non mais là c'est pas parce que dans
ce qu'ils ont pas aimé c'est la france
qui en assume à sion voulais rajouter
voilà c'est très accessoire trésorier
patrick s'achever dans tous les films
isabelle risque explique très bien elle
dit elle doit faire quelqu'un qui pèse
145 kg elle dieu merci pour elle ne
laissez plus elle me dit il n'ya pas
d'actrice en france qui pèse 145 kg de
riz on est obligé de me mettre un acte
un artifice alors là franchement c'est à
choquer son nom on est maintenant est de
toute façon à partir du moment où on
veut montrer voilà ça c'est un handicap
et qu'on montre la réalité mais
finalement ça choque les gens parce
qu'on dit de certains termes
alors que c'est la réalité session s'est
pas compris alors moi mais en tout cas
je trouvais que c'était plutôt réussi ça
plutôt très bien marché doc gynéco vous
avez suivi un petit peu de quoi on parle
et 1
bah oui vous parler d'eux mais moi je
veux jouer dans sauvez willy on adore je
la tends mon but il a des petits je
t'aime bien mon frérot rallye